can I just start by saying this movie is
one of my favorite films to come out of
Indian Cinema in a number of years it's
just
I'm so heartened and happy to hear that
thank you so much that means a lot it's
incredible and it's so poignant IT
addresses so many real issues body
shaming colorism sexism when you're
tackling such massive ideologies that
are really quite deep rooted is there a
conversation you have to have in your
class to prepare them for that you know
it was um I was firstly blessed with a
tremendous cast
um you know and shanu Sharma who's the
casting director deserves full credit
for actually giving me such eclectic and
fantastic artists
um you know from dharamji shabanaji
jokes
besides Rocky and Rania I was talking
about the Ensemble they were also
fantastic that when they all read the
script I remember
shabanaji telling me when she read it
and she says you know Karan is a very
clever film I said clever why do you say
that she says because in the Garb of
entertainment you're saying a lot but
never but never preaching it never
preaching it never making it look like a
sermon but you're saying so much she
said that's why I call it a clever film
and I was like well that's a first no
one's ever called a film of mine ever
before so I'm like okay there are lots
of persons in this film starting with
the fact that Shabana has been founded
clever no and she's absolutely right I
think it's that values that really makes
this film work and really helps it
strike a chord in a way that doesn't
feel like you're sitting in a thriller
um I know you've never really shied away
from telling stories that challenge to
the norm or really sort of play on the
thoughts of society when you're creating
a film that really goes for the jugular
but still aims to leave a last or
impression how do you strike that
balance you know that this in my DNA I'm
completely a big fan of Hindi and Indian
Cinema
um I've grown up watching Cinema from
the time that I can remember since then
I'm six or seven years old all I've done
is watch Hindi Cinema of the year
um Indian Cinema from everywhere heard
any Hindi from music uh so that sense of
mainstream is very much in my own DNA uh
but because
um I constantly believe in the process
of evolution I I believe you have to
constantly grow not just as a filmmaker
but also as a human being uh so I've
I've made so many corrective measures to
my personality and to my ideologies
um in the last two decades a lot of
those transformative swords made their
way into this film through the absolute
Genius of my writing team
uh they really gave the film The
gravitas that it needed emotionally and
then I gave get the the scale and the
Grandeur and the songs all of which I
absolutely loved yeah you know I love it
like whether it's a chiffon sorry in
Kashmir or it's the big dance set pieces
or it's the high like tuned up to 11
melodrama these are things I loved grown
upon and unabashedly unapologetically
wanted to do but within the domain of
that I also felt like it was critical
for me to say something
um filmmakers are in a very very
privileged position where they can
communicate so much through uh their
movies and stories and I feel like if I
don't take leverage of that privilege
then I haven't really Justified being a
filmmaker so I'm glad I could do that
with this one definitely and I think as
I've said I think that is really the
sort of perfect balance that you have to
find I think when you're covering so
many topics it's so easy for it to come
across like oh sure it's heavy but it
doesn't and I think that's what really
works about it
um so I know you've spoken a lot about
these characters being born out of
personal experience and you know a part
of you sort of being placed in each of
the characters to some degree does you
know implementing your own experiences
your own vulnerabilities does it amplify
the pressure to get it right or does it
just make it even that much more of a
classroom project no it kind of makes it
easier because I like the character of
angeliana who played golu in the film um
I've been a plus-sized child for a large
part of my my childhood
um I was also an effeminate child and
have combated some kind of like shaming
as a result of that so I believe Toyota
is uh the Qatar dancing powder and
Anjali and who played golu but very
close to my heart as characters you know
I've also uh up close them a personal
viewed many households in where I've
seen the you know patriarchy that is
that's that is that is just seems to
many as the way of life and I'm like to
me I come from very Progressive
parenting where um we never had a
patriarchal household my mother was
really pretty much the leader at home
and my father and I were like literally
puppies following her all around the
place like doing it so I grew up and I
grew up with a group of aunts
um there were all super Progressive and
all said the most like amazingly uh like
uh Progressive things uh so I never once
felt that these characters were
uncomfortable for me to express having
said that I haven't done this in my
earlier films because I was following
the Norms of the cinema I grew up on
then but with each age and evolution you
go you go back into your basic roots and
your basic ideologies and so for me I
was never uncomfortable I was at home
because at home this is how things are I
love that and just a sort of wrap up
there are so many brilliant parallels
and references
I think it's a feast for anybody who
loves your films was there anything
brought from the set of coffee we come
to this one that really helps guide that
or was it just kind of you know like
brain waves oh just no no no just some
of the dialogue when I made Jesus
like I mean I was like we all in the set
got so excited like it was so that was
an improvisation there was affordable
gasp in the cinema so there was an
audible upset as well because it was not
in the dialogue and she said she said
yeah and I was like oh my God we have to
add the candy and she was like oh God
you're making me say uh my husband's
lying and I was like like we're flipping
it all on its head you know
um I've done many there are many nods
too many films uh not just my own in the
film you know there's a throwback
feeling uh because
um they're such an old it's an old and
homashed Nostalgia to current filmmakers
like yes ali
um I felt like this film was much more
than just a story but it's organic
celebration of Cinema that I have loved
grown up on and continue to love today
and it's absolutely beautiful then
thank you congratulations